hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing and the first game
that ended basically uh from round one
of this year's scene field cup uh it is
magnus cross and versus yanipongoshi so
the two players that should have played
the world church championship match uh
next year but as magnus decided not to
defend his title uh yanni palmishi will
face dingler and the magnus uh well he
he will sort of not be the champion but
uh uh well uh whoever wins the world
chess championship title will have to
prove themselves a lot for for
the entire world to consider them uh to
be number one and this game is uh a good
example of that now as it's the first
game we'll be showing and it's classical
chess a little bit about the tournament
so the singfield cup is a 10 player
classical round robin tournament uh
in the in the past it was sort of a
double round robin if you remember
fabiano caruana wanted brilliantly in
2014 he had like uh
eight and a half out of ten six wins and
three draws and he
uh finished three full points ahead of
magnus carlsen so that was a spectacular
achievement and if magnus wants to
continue towards his goal of achieving
that 2900 classical rating he will need
at least
six out of nine in this tournament which
is not an easy thing to do as this is
classical uh but we'll see so like i
said it's taking place in saint louis
chess club uh
over the course of the next nine days uh
it is the fifth and final stage of the
2022 grand chess tour uh and uh a series
of five events with a total price of uh
1.4 million dollars the time control is
19 minutes for 40 moves followed by 30
minutes to the end of the game and as
usual plus a 30 seconds increment
after
you make a move starting from move one
so it's a very exciting game let's check
it out magnus has the white pieces and
he opens with pawn to d4 uh we have
knight to f6 by nippo c for e6 and now
knight to f3 uh nepo checking of course
if if magnus is feeling a bit wild maybe
he would be interested in uh going for
or rather allowing jan to go for the
nimzo indian but magnus says let's keep
to the classical stuff knight f3 we have
d5 now with the standard queen's gambit
the client is on the board and now
magnus plays c captures on d5 now this
is interesting as this is only the fifth
most popular reply here uh standard ones
being knight to c3 or you could go for
the catalan with g3 or bishop to g5 or
or maybe e3 but that magnus goes for c
captures on d5 so the early trade and
this is very popular nowadays
uh he captures on the e5 and now comes
knight to c3
uh we have c6 uh defending the d5 pawn
and now bishop to f4 bishop to g5 is
still the more popular line but bishop
to f4 kind of kind of makes sense
because uh uh when you're first
thought how to play chess you're uh you
know okay bishop g5 pins the knight you
are fighting for the center but here c6
already defends d5 so it's not like you
are
fighting for the center all that much
and it's uh played much much less so
magnus of course wants to test nipples
preparation so bishop to f5 we have e3
knight beat to d7 and now comes pawn to
h3 a very a very rare way of
challenging this structure uh nakamura
played that job played it so it is
played on the highest level uh we have
the shop the e7 and now pawn to g4
immediately going for this expansion and
now usually in all the games that this
happened the bishop the g6 was played
but there is one game where bishop the
e4 was played and interestingly it is a
game where magnus had the black pieces
so here nipple says i know my stuff very
well i'm throwing the exact same move uh
that you used uh to defeat vishwanathan
on the in the uh in the 2009 the world
blitz championship so here
for the moment
magnus is basically playing against
himself but uh anand in that game
defended with bishop to g2 that was a
blitz game but now magnus plays bishop
to e2 this is the strongest move
recommended by the engine so magnus also
knows his stuff and it is now as of
muftander we have a completely new game
and where the game basically begins uh
so here queen to b6 nepo develops the
queen goes after the b2 pawn and uh of
course the queen to b3 is expected as an
early queen trade
uh it is common in positions like these
so queen b3 uh nipple trades queen
captures eight captures and now bishop
back to g6 nepal not interested in
allowing uh the the capture here but
magnus says nope you will not be
enjoying the bishop fair this game sir
so okay bishop b4 now maybe with some
knight to e4 action as the c3 knight is
spinned but magnus just trades captures
captures and plays pawn to f3 now this
does give nipple the semi-open h file so
magnus will have to deal with this h3
pawn being a little bit weak but it's
gonna get pushed to h4 so it's gonna be
uh it's gonna be okay and also you can
bring your king to the g3 and so on so
here knight to f8 re-maneuvering the
knight the e6 to put pressure on the
bishop king f2
and knight to e6 we have bishop to g3
and now king to e7 connecting the rooks
finally h4 by magnus and now pawn to a6
we have king to g2 freeing up the f2
square for the bishop here
rook 8 to d8 and now bishop to f2 so
just putting pieces on optimal squares
we have bishop back to d6 and now bishop
to d3
uh bishop back to b8 by nipple and here
we have knight the a4 trying to take
advantage of the dark squares here uh
but nepo just goes back bishop to d6
takes control over the c5 square and at
some point of course you are expecting
nipple to push c5 capture on d4 and if
the situation clears up on the king side
as of course the h4 pawn is fairly well
defended you might even consider
doubling up rooks on the c file so here
bishop to e1 by magnus uh he's hinting
that maybe he can do something along
this diagonal but this is only an
illusion and nipple shows why he plays
c5 uh now interestingly uh of course the
bishop to a5 comes to mind i mean you
can't put it there so why not try it the
the thing is if you play the move like
this although it seems like you should
be okay and you are attacking the rook
here uh the position would be lost for
you and it's a super fun line c captures
on the for you you just give up the rook
and after bishop captures rook captures
your position is lost the problem is the
knight on a4 is stuck there's no way to
get it away from there and if you try
something like let's say rook h to e1
king to f8 getting away from the e file
let's say rook a to d1 or something
doesn't really matter at some point the
d captures an e3 rook captures knight f4
check
king somewhere and now b5 that's the
problem of white's position and the
knight now is stuck if you go to b6
bishop c5 and it's game over and if you
try something else let's say you try
knight to c3 then d4 and again it's game
over so
uh you have to be careful if considering
moves like this so here knight captures
on c5 as nepo did push it so magnus
trades knight captures on c5 with d
captures bishop captures attacking the
e3 pawn and now just bishop to d3 so now
magnus has the bishop fair nipple has
the isolated d-pawn and he still has his
king in the center of the board so it is
a bit better for magnus but with uh
perfect play should be okay for nipple
rook h38 he now says all right
as long as my rook is on h8 your rook
will be on h1 so we might as well move
them but magnus first goes b4 challenges
the bishop on c5 bishop to b6 and now
magnus shows how to fully utilize the
power of the bishop pair he pushes the
pawn all the way to b5 which would not
be possible if the pawn was not on b4
and now the lines towards the black king
open up this is now becomes possible if
nipple trades here and we will show this
because what do you do if you don't
trade there's uh the pawn is attacking
a6 the bishop is attacking rook is
attacking so you're going to lose a pawn
if you don't capture it the problem is
if you capture it you allow bishop b for
check king e6 and now bishop captures on
b5 and look at this black king uh you
know
in front of all of these pawns and
everything like what do you play here
you have to move the rook somewhere rook
8 the e1 now comes and that black king
will not survive in the center of the
board so after b5 nipple says uh all
right i i seem to have
lost the pawn here i'm going to have to
give it up so the best way to give it up
would be pawn to a5 and okay bishop
captures on a5 magnus wins the pawn
bishop captures we have rook captures on
a5 and now king to d6
uh he will try of course to maybe bring
the king to b6 but uh
it's uh that's easier said than done we
have king to f2 and now we have rook to
e7
a good way to try and counter magnus is
rook to a8 but
who's to say who's to say what's what
here so rook to e7 by nipple
and now magnus plays rook to d1 and uh
we i will return to this position
because uh here the position is
objectively winning for magnus and the
if you follow for example the norwegian
supercomputer sese that follows all of
magnus's games as cece gives the b6 here
as completely winning for uh for magnus
uh point being that the g7 pawn is weak
that's weird but that's super computer
chess and i will show the line if any of
you guys are interested
after we check out the game because it's
quite quite a you know a large sausage
of a line so okay magnus played rook to
d1 and now uh nipple goes back rook to
h8 he goes after the h4 pawn g5 now uh
kicks away the knight knights to d7 and
now rook to a4 and now magnus is saying
i'm just gonna pile up on the d for uh a
d5 pawn and there's really nothing you
can do about this uh also very very
interesting is pawn to b6 uh it's it's a
fine line because uh how do you how do
you counter this there's really no good
way to do it and e4 is coming uh this
will open up lines towards the black
king and if you capture it then rook b5
is incredibly strong you can't go after
it if you go kink the c6 we can just
kick away the king would rook the uh
rook the c1 but there's really nothing
better or even if king the c6 you can
play e4 it's even even nicer if captures
rook c1 check kicks away the king away
from the defense of the knight for
example king to d7 uh and okay your
bishop is hanging but you might play
bishop capture sunny for and again the
position just um
[Music]
is not playable for for black so okay
after 97 magnus decides to go a a
different route he goes rook a4 he wants
to play rook d4 go after the d5 pawn and
now knight to c5 attacking the rook and
the bishop and now magnus moves the rook
all the way to g4 uh problem is if you
go somewhere like rook to d4 right away
which was nepo's idea if magnus plays
rogue d4 then knight e6 you know you
still can't capture the bishop is in
between the rooks and if you move the
rook again then king c5 and all of a
sudden black is fine if rook c1 check
king to b6 and this is not perfectly
fine for black so magnus plays rook all
the way to g4 even though it looks very
weird and now nepo should play knight
captures on d3 with check it's not great
for black but uh it's it is the best for
example rook captures and you are now
expecting magnus to double up on the d
file but maybe you can defend with rook
d7 and if now rook here king moves and
now of course if you capture the h
four pawn falls as well kind of being
the point but nepal played king to c7
and this is now completely winning for
magnus but you have to figure out why so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this elusive idea
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
wild move and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is bishop back
to b1 i know you guys found this so
congratulations you are a true master of
winning isolated pawns and uh for those
of you of course who just want to enjoy
the show uh the idea is bishop a2 going
after the pawn in rook d4 and then the
pawn cannot be saved
and
there's really no good way to counter
this uh
situation on the clock if you guys are
interested magnus has some 14 minutes
nipple has over 30 minutes on the clock
but it doesn't matter point is that if
you defend the pawn let's say rugged age
just broke gd4 and now if rookie d7 just
bishop a2 that's the idea behind bishop
to b1 and as magnus is already up upon
winning another pawn is is uh far more
than magnus needs so here nipple tries
rook the e5
but
it's not much better magnus just goes
bishop a2 attacking the pawn and now
nipple tries f6 there's no defending the
pawn so you might as well try something
else
g captures g captures and now rook
captures on d5 we have rook captures
bishop captures and not knight to d3
with check we have king g3 and yes you
could go after the b2 pawn but the g6
pawn is hanging as well so knight here
defending and attacking and now just a
rook f4 attacking the f6 pawn and
there's just no good way to play this
nipple played rook to d8 attacks the
bishop but magnus just throws in a nice
b6 which would not be possible if you
did not play pawn to b4 and then pawn to
b5 now that notice that all of those
pawn pushes were uh just the absolute
best moves for magnus in any given
possession and here there's just no way
to continue playing this game so he was
in this position on mu
the annie punisher resigned in the game
and a brilliant brilliant victory for
magnus carlsen in round one of this
year's sinful cup which brings him a
little bit closer to that 2900 rating
so here you resign because if you if you
accept the pawn than just throw captures
on f6 this comes with checks so black
now cannot capture the bishop and once
you move the king then just you move the
bishop and everything will fall this
falls next or if you defend this this
falls next so
magnus will just be up too many pawns
and if you don't capture the pawn it
doesn't even matter there are even
tricks like if king b6 then you still
capture the pawn and now okay you can
capture the bishop but you get
checkmated because the pawn is now
preventing the king from escaping so
it's a disgusting position to be in
especially in a classical game but uh
you know
that's what sometimes happens when when
you play against magnus and he has a
very good day
like he did today so so i don't forget i
mentioned that there was a really really
fun super computer line after nipple
played this rook the e7 move and that is
the immediate b6 of course magnus
thought about this but uh
he thought that his chances were just as
good it would rook to d1
because at some point rook will come to
d1 but i will show it uh for those of
you who really are interested pawn to b6
is just uh
spectacular uh now how can black
continue this well let's get the knight
into the game knight to d7 as g5 is
coming in also you want to pick up this
b6 pawn but there's no good way to pick
it up just e4 by magnus now would uh
could be played and now if you go for b6
then just rule b5 and that's uh
again
you will have to move the knight then uh
uh
it's just uh it's just really really
really bad i mean for example if the if
the uh sorry if d captures an e4 bishop
captures uh this cannot uh you cannot
hold this it's
it's just a silly silly position you
can't go near the knight because then
rook to c1 kicks the king away and then
you lose the knight so it's just really
really bad so basically what you would
have to do here after e4 is just go for
this d captures an e4 now comes bishop
captures going after the b7 pawn and
again no good way of of dealing with
this for example if rook to e6 now rook
to e7
rook to a7 and after king the e7 now
you're gonna play rook captures on b7
and win this pawn because if you
don't do this if you somehow try to
defend it let's say move the knight
knight f6 attacks the bishop also the
pawn is defended there's a rook to d1
check now
the move that magnus actually played in
the game up front as he wanted to have
it ready for you know if if this
situation arose uh but it's uh
completely winning here if you go k6
then just bishop f5 check disgusting g
captures g captures checkmate
uh so that's why even though it seems
like you could capture the pawn you you
you could defend the pawn you really
can't so best here would be just uh
instead of this rook to e6 and then like
we said rook to a7 here you would move
the king the king has to escape
otherwise it was just gonna get
destroyed rook captures on b7 rook
captures on b6 now winning back the
material rook captures knight captures
and now rook to e1 and uh again it seems
like uh magnus is only up upon but the
past b pawn is winning and uh uh we can
even show what the super computer
suggested the rook h8 bishop c2 opens up
a discovery check king d6 now bishop to
b3 goes after f7 rook fade defending now
rook d1 check king to c5 and now king to
g3 we have king to b4 and now bishop
back to a2 we have king to c5 as no good
move can be played here for black and
rook d3 f6 now rook to e3 knights to d5
attacks the rook and just bishop
captures king captures and the rook and
pawn end game is completely winning for
white uh
for example if rook to a7 going after
the pawn you have to defend it rook g8
and now rook to a7 and now you will
start escorting your your b pawn up the
board and if let's say king e6 king f4
king d6 pawn to b for king to c6 now
rook to e7 and now you will uh either
allow the white king into the position
or you will go after the rook and after
rook f7 king e6 now the rule goes here
and now the pawn can start marching
forward or if rogue b8 then you trade
pawns rook captures throw captures with
chuck king g3 rook b5 rook captures and
g6 and of course it's an elementary end
game that absolutely everyone can win so
that's the idea the super computer had
with uh playing b6 right away it's of
course silly to mention such things uh
you know in terms of should someone have
played it but i know you guys uh for
some reason are interested in in lines
like that
uh but yeah magnus pulled off a nice one
here after b6 check
basically magnus finished with the move
that the super computer suggested like
20 moves ago
so which is funny uh but yeah uh that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it and
this little bit of extra super computer
nonsense uh i would like to thank
frederick carragher petrogly gerald
watts wood and thanks for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
sink filled cup until it finishes as i
am uh seeing some other very fine games
are being played so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day and remember this was all
made possible by pushing over the b-pawn
see you soon